many of all of our plans for
thanksgiving have changed this year
because of the coronavirus
and that means more of us could be
prepping our very first turkey day meal
this time
federal health officials want to remind
everyone about proper food safety
practices to avoid getting sick
the usda says when it's time to cook the
bird it's best to use a food thermometer
also make sure you are not
cross-contaminating wash and sanitize
all the surfaces
cutting boards utensils and your hands
wash your hands before you prepare food
wash your hands
during food preparation if you're
handling something raw
or something that could be contaminated
and wash your hands
afterward 95 to 99
of our consumers in observational
studies don't
wash your hands at all or they don't
properly wash your hands
yes we need to wash your hands you don't
want to leave the food out all day
either
get those leftovers into the fridge
within two hours and put them in a
smaller container so they chill quickly
and toss everything after four days
that's the magic number
the american farm bureau federation
reports thanksgiving dinner will cost
less this year a traditional meal for 10
people is expected to cost about 47
bucks
a person that's four percent cheaper
than last year a 16 pound turkey cost
about 20
and that is also down from last year
federation says stores are discounting
turkeys
since more people will likely be trying
to cook on their own